he's looking at these old school witch
from like Snow White
definitions I'm a mother witch ho like
how are you not getting
that she's a witch with an attitude you
got to be careful around her just
kidding she says she's a good witch I'm
Linda The Witch of the North I'm all
about helping people get to their best
version of
sth Ashley and men will get into an
argument the first day he arrives in
America after Ashley insists that he
accepts her as a witch meanwhile he
doesn't believe she's
one this is 90day replay travel size
where I pack in all you need to know
while keeping it light hey 90-day fans
fam it's melissia all right let's get
into the new 90day couple menuel and
Ashley yes I'm a black Ashley we're
unicorns Ashley is 32 from Rochester New
York and Manuel is 35 from Ecuador I met
Manuel on New Year's Eve over 10 years
ago on this week's episode Manuel
arrives in America for the first time
and their 90 days to get married
officially starts they also start
bumping
heads the first issue that comes up for
these two is Ashley's dog Rico Suave
sleeping in the
bed
[Music]
I'm not sure why they didn't discuss
this before I would be worried about
Manuel rolling over on L
Rico we've had a crazy ass first day and
Men well tried about three or four times
to say okay we go floor and weo jump
back up because that's what Rico knows
so I'm hoping over time Manuel will
realize that's a battle that he's not
going to win my dog does what he wants
he's a god a
god wow I've come across a lot of dog
lovers never heard that
one after the back and forth around Rico
Suave Ashley decides to introduce Manuel
to her witchcraft practices and his face
says it all why
for
[Music]
no Ashley continues to insist that
Manuel accepts her as a
witch why is she so attached to being
labeled as
that I don't
know yeah her definition turns out to be
very different from
Googles
the conversation gets Ashley pretty
heated to a point where she needs to
step outside to get some miror can I
just like V please this witch thing is
going to be hard to to navigate through
cuz he's not understanding he's looking
at these old school wit from like Snow
White
definitions I'm a mother witch ho like
how are you not getting that it's just a
label though Ashley I get that she wants
to break the stigma around being a witch
but in my opinion that label doesn't
Define the work that she does based off
of what she told me it sounds like she's
much more than that
I'm a Seer I'm a Healer I work in
spirituality I help people build their
online brands in spirituality I work
with tarot astrology the acostic records
I'm all about helping people get to
their best version of self that's what I
do and so we use magic to do this we use
manifestation to do this we use Mantra
work to do this we use all sorts of
things to do this yeah why she wants to
be called a witch so bad is something I
hope we gain a little bit more
understanding on as the season continues
use all right 90day fan spam make sure
you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next
[Music]
time